[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans un nouveau
numéro de VIP en compagnie de Sandrine
narciset bonjour Sandrine merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors Sandrine
vous êtes animatrice de télévision
journaliste prof de fitness à la télé
aussi auteur et également yvelinoise
vous nous avez d'ailleurs accueilli chez
vous dans les Yvelines alors on va
parler de votre carrière de votre
attachement aux Yvelines et on commence
avec votre dernière actualité la sortie
très prochainement d'un nouveau livre
alors en quelques mots de quoi va parler
ce livre alors c'est un livre que j'ai
réalisé avec mon fils enfin un livre
pour toute la famille on propose des des
séances entre guillemets parce que c'est
plus des exercices des jeux pour faire
du sport mais en famille avec ses
enfants donc j'ai remarqué que en fait
pendant le confinement je faisais des
séances tout tous les soirs en live sur
sur Facebook Instagram etc avec ses 8 et
Gym Direct et mon fils invitait aux
séances et j'ai remarqué que ça a
vraiment plu aux gens et que ça
permettait de bouger tous ensemble parce
que parfois c'est pas évident de trouver
du temps pour bouger les enfants sont
beaucoup devant les écrans
et pas ils sont ils sont il y en a pas
mal qui sont sédentaire donc voilà que
ce soit les adultes ou les enfants donc
j'ai voilà j'ai décidé de continuer dans
voilà comme ça comme ce que j'avais fait
pendant le confinement de continuer et
voilà avec un avec un livre qui n'est
pas encore sorti ou et bien voilà on
fait des exercices et on s'amuse
beaucoup on rigole et en même temps ça
permet vraiment aux gens de bouger en
famille avec leurs enfants et ça c'est
hyper important et justement comme votre
dernier livre mais également ce que vous
faites sur C8 le votre enjeu vous c'est
de faire faire du sport à tout le monde
c'est hyper important pour les personnes
qui ont l'habitude de faire du sport
c'est hyper important parce que c'est
vraiment de faire du sport c'est très
bon pour sa santé pour son moral pour
sont bien-être donc c'est hyper hyper
important que les gens bougent ne
serait-ce que un petit peu un quart
d'heure une demi-heure je sais qu'on a
des des plannings hyper remplis et c'est
souvent difficile de s'accorder du temps
mais ça fait vraiment du bien de s'aérer
la tête et puis voilà de prendre soin de
soi et donc c'est pour ça que alors j'ai
fait d'abord j'ai fait tout d'abord ce
livre là que je vous présente
ma coach Gym Direct je l'ai fait avec C8
et les éditions First et là vraiment
c'est des séances avec du renforcement
musculaire pour l'ensemble du corps du
cardio du stretching etc et mon nouveau
livre c'est plus vraiment pour la
famille avec aussi des exercices mais un
peu plus dans le jeu pour que tout le
monde s'y retrouve pour que aussi les
enfants aient envie de bouger j'ai
vraiment envie de faire bouger tout le
monde et il faut que tout le monde bouge
c'est hyper hyper important surtout pour
sa santé ce qu'on a une date pour ce
prochain on y va à peu près à la rentrée
ouais à la rentrée alors votre pour le
sport on l'a compris c'est important
elle est venue dès l'enfance c'est ça
dès l'enfance moi j'ai toujours fait du
sport alors je faisais du patinage c'est
du patinage artistique après j'ai fait
de la danse sur glace du patinage
synchronisé j'adorais faire du patinage
c'est vraiment une découverte j'habitais
à côté d'une patinoire dans le 95 donc
du coup bah ouais c'est plus facile pour
moi donc c'est pour ça que j'ai fait du
patinol donc ça m'a suivi vraiment toute
mon adolescence j'ai commencé à aller
vers l'âge de 7 ans donc ça m'a suivi
après toute mon adolescence bon j'ai vu
que c'était pas non plus j'allais pas
faire les choses olympiques donc voilà
je me suis après j'ai voilà je me suis
dit je vais faire un autre sport et je
me suis mise en fitness parce qu'à côté
de chez moi il y avait il y avait des
cours de fitness pour les jeunes et pour
les jeunes adultes et du coup voilà je
me suis mis dedans et ça m'a plu du tout
quitté et effectivement je fais du sport
depuis que je suis toute petite c'est
hyper important pour moi et ça me fait
vraiment du bien et je trouve que quand
à un moment donné de sa vie
voilà on est un peu stressé ça va pas
très bien c'est vraiment le meilleur des
médicaments c'est de s'aérer la tête et
de alors ça peut être n'importe quel
sport c'est pas obligé que ce soit du
fitness c'est vraiment être n'importe
quel sport elle est courir même juste
marcher ça irait la tête pour voilà
penser à autre chose et revenir bien et
vraiment ça fait du bien je conseille à
tout le monde et justement il y a un
moment de votre vie où j'ai cru
comprendre que ça vous ça vous avait
aidé en 2019 on vous diagnostique un
anévrisme de l'aorte thoracique et une
insuffisance cardiaque alors on va s'en
suivre opération qu'on va l'essence
est-ce que le sport a eu un rôle
important pour récupérer un rôle majeur
vraiment ça vous a manqué pendant cette
période de pause qui a été obligatoire
ça m'a pas manqué parce que j'étais
vraiment dans une période très
compliquée où je pensais vraiment à
autre chose pour le coup mais après
l'opération pour la réadaptation
cardiaque finalement on nous remet sur
pied très vite c'est-à-dire qu'au début
on travaille avec des kinés mais tout de
suite peut-être après l'opération on
travaille avec des kinés à l'hôpital et
à ce que vous avez une opération à cœur
ouvert j'ai une opération à cœur ouvert
donc voilà après il faut vraiment faire
une réadaptation cardiaque parce que le
coeur a été arrêté voilà enfin il y a
une grosse opération tout de même donc
après il faut on ressort assez affaibli
de cette opération ce qui ce qui est
logique et donc après il faut reprendre
vie tout doucement et donc j'ai
recommencé donc à refaire des exercices
donc avec des kinés puis ensuite j'ai
fait une réadaptation cardiaque dans un
dans un centre à Paris et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait mais on fait on fait du
fitness finalement on fait du tapis de
marche au début on essaie de lever les
bras tant bien que mal
adaptant avec ce nouveau corps
exactement et
finalement c'est assez revenu assez
rapidement mais c'est ça m'a fait
vraiment du bien parce que quand j'étais
là-bas je me sentais vraiment bien
j'étais dans mon élément même si je
faisais plus du tout ce que je faisais
avant parce que je enfin vraiment
du mal à lever les jambes et les bras
mais ça finalement le corps il est hyper
bien fait et ça revient
pas moi en tous les cas pour mon cas
c'est revenu assez facilement et donc au
bout d'un mois ça allait mieux au bout
de trois mois j'étais vraiment sur pied
puis après il y a eu le confinement donc
pour moi pour le coup il est tombé au
bon moment parce que j'étais chez moi et
j'ai fait des séances de sport tous les
soirs avec les gens en live et ça m'a
permis de reprendre confiance en moi de
voir que ça y est c'était bon je pouvais
repartir je pouvais refaire du cardio
ressauter dans tous les sens et ça m'a
ça ça m'a vraiment manqué et du coup bah
voilà c'est reparti et le sport était
hyper essentiel et moi j'ai vraiment
pour les gens qui se font opérer du cœur
ou autre si on vous donne ça fait partie
de la guérison aussi faire il faut les
faire c'est hyper important parce que
parfois il y a des gens qui comment ça
c'est bon ils se sont fait opérer et
puis basta ils vont pas faire leur
séance de kiné ou de sport ou de
réadaptation etc de rééducation
et je pense que c'est vraiment hyper
important de de les faire pour aller
plus vite dans la guérison et pour même
dans son esprit de son moral c'est assez
compliqué quand même tous les cas pour
moi c'était compliqué et ben ça fait du
bien vraiment ça fait du bien et
justement est-ce que cette expérience ça
vous a permis aussi de vous adapter
peut-être plus aux personnes qui
commencent le sport qui sont malades ça
vous a vous qui êtes sportif de nature
ça fait changer un petit peu le la
vision du sport c'est vrai que quand on
se retrouve comme ça moi je suis rentrée
à l'hôpital j'étais comme ça sur sortie
vraiment j'avais pris des années en fait
j'avais du mal à marcher j'arrivais pas
à bien lever les bras et tout voilà
j'avais une grosse cicatrice et tout ça
et du coup effectivement on se rend
compte quand tout va bien on fait pas
attention finalement c'est naturel c'est
naturel donc on fait pas attention
vraiment à ce qui pourrait se passer ou
comment on pourrait être et en fait
effectivement là je me suis rendu compte
que ça peut être compliqué difficile
et donc il faut s'adapter vraiment à
chacun et ça c'est hyper important je
vais toujours fait tout de même mais mes
séances de sport elles sont ouvertes à
tous c'est à dire que j'essaie vraiment
de de faire des cours intermédiaires
pour que tout le monde puisse accéder et
si c'est trop facile et bien on peut
augmenter un peu soit le cardio soit
prendre des poids plus lourds par
exemple il y a toujours moyen de
s'adapter d'adapter les séances
difficiles on peut ralentir un petit peu
voilà au niveau de la séance j'ai tout
je me suis toujours adapté mais c'est
vrai que là on en prend encore plus
conscience en disant ah oui ça peut être
compliqué tout de même il faut toujours
faire du sport en fonction de soi et de
voir que au fur et à mesure et bien on
prend confiance et on s'améliore et
c'est ça qui est sympa c'est de voir que
on peut progresser dans le sport ou dans
d'autres activités et ça c'est c'est
gratifiant alors justement toutes ces
choses vous vous en servez également à
télévision sur C8 ou vous présentez
depuis 18 ans c'est ça maintenant
l'émission Gym Direct alors comment
s'est passé au tout début cette
collaboration avec C8
ça s'est passé en fait je suis arrivée
sur C8 il cherchait à l'époque ça
s'appelait Direct 8 et il cherchait
d'ailleurs le nom de l'émission est
restée avec le direct
parce qu'à l'époque c'est huit qui était
direct depuis tout était en direct donc
c'est pour ça qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'émissions avec le mot direct dedans
donc
en fait il cherchait il savait qu'il
voulait faire une émission de sport et
faire faire bouger les gens ça avait pas
trop comment la faire et moi je suis
arrivée c'était vraiment mon domaine
donc voilà ça a été hyper naturel et on
est en j'ai monté avec eux l'émission au
début il y avait que moi qui l'animait
et puis comme maintenant j'ai d'autres
activités et bien on a ouvert l'émission
à d'autres coachs ce qui fait que c'est
la plus grande salle de sport gratuite
en France parce que vraiment on peut on
peut la retrouver on peut on peut faire
ses séances ou surtout à n'importe
quelle heure à n'importe quel moment et
gratuitement donc ça c'est plutôt plutôt
bien pour les gens et avec des coachs
différents donc il y a plein de cours
spécialité donc de la danse de la boxe
du Pilates du stress enfin voilà du
renforcement musculaire maman il y en a
pour tout le monde et donc j'invite tout
le monde à s'entraîner avec avec Gym
Direct et justement ça fait 18 ans que
ça dure ça marche plutôt bien comment
vous expliquer que ça continue de
marcher aussi bien aujourd'hui il y a
plein de vidéos en ligne sur YouTube par
exemple avec des cours de sport mais ça
reste un rendez-vous pour les gens ça
reste un rendez-vous parce que c'est
vraiment un cours de sport comme on va
le retrouver en salle avec souvent un
tout la plupart du temps un échauffement
le corps de séance un retour au calme on
s'attache aussi aux coach qu'on retrouve
chacun à sa personnalité sa spécialité
et donc c'est vraiment un rendez-vous
voilà alors c'est tôt le matin lorsqu'on
s'est diffusé mais après de garder quand
on peut voilà il y a tous les replay sur
mycanal ensuite il y a youtube il y a le
Facebook enfin de Gym Direct donc
vraiment là on peut pas passer à côté on
peut vraiment le regarder partout et
surtout suivre et faire la séance et moi
c'est les gens ont l'habitude de moi
parce que ça fait tellement longtemps
que j'ai créé l'émission donc ça fait
tellement de sport avec nous aussi et
donc et c'est génial quand je reçois des
messages qui me disent je vous suis
depuis le début ou en tous les cas vous
m'avez aidé à perdre du poids ou vous
m'avez aidé parce que j'ai j'étais pas
bien et que grâce à vous j'ai repris le
sourire et enfin des messages comme ça
des témoignages comme ça ça fait
vraiment ça fait vraiment chaud au coeur
on se dit qu'on fait quelque chose de
bien tout de même et c'est super et
malgré la distance de la télé vous avez
quand même des retours des gens et un
lien particulier avec vraiment vraiment
en plus maintenant avec les réseaux
sociaux c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus
simple et les gens n'hésitent pas à
m'écrire et je l'ai vu pendant le
confinement c'était vraiment c'est une
grosse communauté et c'est hyper hyper
sympa les gens sont sont
cools sont contents de retrouver
justement ces séances qui peuvent qui
peuvent faire n'importe où n'importe
quand ça leur fait du bien on le sent ça
leur aère la tête c'est pas que pour le
physique souvent on dit le voilà le
sport c'est que pour les tablettes de
chocolat genre des fessiers des fessiers
bombés c'est vraiment pas que pour le
physique mais c'est ce que je dis c'est
génial effectivement on peut se sculpter
un corps mais c'est vraiment pour soi il
faut vraiment d'abord le prendre pour
soi et pour comme je le disais pour sa
santé franchement c'est les cardiologues
le disent 30 minutes de sport au moins
par jour pour son cœur c'est nécessaire
et c'est pas moi qui vais vous dire le
contraire en tous les cas ça ça fait
vraiment du bien il faut quand on en
fait pas il faut s'y mettre
alors bon on l'a compris le sport une
grande passion il y a une autre passion
que vous exercez à la télé c'est celle
des animaux vous animez les animaux de
la vie depuis plusieurs années est-ce
que vous avez des anecdotes de raconter
des moments marquants alors des
anecdotes j'en ai beaucoup parce qu'en
fait les animaux de la 8 c'est vraiment
une aventure que je fais avec avec ma
complice Elodie et toute mon équipe à
chaque fois on part dans toute la France
dans toutes les régions de France donc
déjà on visite on partage les décors
fabuleux voilà exactement les décors
fabuleux que l'on retrouve en France et
puis on va à la rencontre de personnes
vraiment passionnantes qui donnent tout
pour leurs animaux des passionnés
d'animaux mais que ça peut être des
vétos ça peut être juste des passionnés
qui ont plein d'animaux chez eux comment
ils font pour s'en occuper ça peut être
des soigneurs animaliers c'est c'est
vraiment c'est assez large on va
rencontrer des animaux de compagnie
domestiques des animaux sauvages
également et oui et on va à l'étranger
aussi parfois donc nos aventures
continuent aussi à l'étranger une à deux
fois par an et
il se passe je sais pas j'ai eu des
chèvres qui ont cru que mes cheveux
c'était de la paille qui m'ont mangé des
bouts de cheveux
on en a tout le temps on se retrouve
parfois parce que nous on tourne tout le
temps qu'il pleuve qu'il neige il a de
la boue on est tout le temps dehors et
donc on peut avoir la voiture qui est
restée coincée dans la glace et c'est un
cheval un cheval de trait qui est venu
nous tracter la voiture enfin deux
chevaux qui sont qui est venu tracter la
voiture parce qu'on était coincé dans la
neige ouais c'est vraiment en pleine
immersion et et tout le monde est mis à
contribution c'est à dire que toute
l'équipe
est dans la même galère quand il y a des
galères
mais c'est vraiment une émission hyper
sympa une mission ludique pédagogique
pour toute la famille
le dimanche matin c'est une émission
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on nous dit c'est
une émission qui fait du bien il y a
toujours du making-of à la fin ou dans
les séquences ce qui nous arrive
toujours des aventures assez incroyables
donc c'est une c'est une belle émission
c'est pas parce que c'est moi qui l'a
fait mais je trouve que c'est quand même
une très belle émission bon alors on l'a
compris une carrière bien remplie une
vie bien remplie vous êtes également
marraine de la team 78 les influenceurs
du département des Yvelines alors
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez choisi les
soutenir et les accompagner parce que
déjà on me l'a demandé et j'ai accepté
vraiment volontiers je trouve que c'est
une super initiative du département de
d'avoir des influenceurs comme ça qui
vont mettre en avant plusieurs actions
du département des actions parfois qu'on
ne connaît même pas nous quand on habite
dans les Yvelines donc ça fait vraiment
ça permet de faire découvrir pas mal de
projets d'action de de choses qui se
font dans les Yvelines donc on a pu
mettre en avant par exemple le marché de
Noël c'était hyper sympa avec tous les
artisans yvelinois donc c'est plutôt
cool de se dire que dans les Yvelines on
a des artisans qui font de très très
belles choses donc de pouvoir les mettre
en avant donc ça c'est et puis c'est
récurrent tous les ans donc on a mis ça
en avant on a mis aussi les centres de
santé sexuelle c'est vraiment aussi
hyper important pour nos jeunes de
pouvoir de savoir qui peuvent avoir
accès à ce service là gratuitement en
plus de ça donc voilà on va mettre en
avant on a mis en avant les archives du
département est-ce que vous avez des
archives dans les Yvelines vous pouvez
retrouver mes petites merveilles des
petites pépites sur sur les Yvelines
même sur notre ville en particulier si
on a envie de savoir des choses sur
l'histoire ou même sur une maison en
particulier bien on se rend aux archives
voilà donc vraiment on met en avant
plein plein d'actions on a mis aussi Eva
et sur du temps et vallée sur du temps
c'est une application qui nous permet
d'en savoir plus sur des lieux donnés
dans les usines dans les chevaux mais
donc voilà donc plein de plein de lieux
différents grâce à cette application il
y a des énigmes et ça nous permet de
mieux comprendre le lieu de savoir plein
de choses sur le lieu c'est hyper sympa
en famille c'est hyper cool de le faire
c'est vraiment une après-midi
sympathique non vraiment on met en avant
plein des actions comme ça c'est très
varié c'est très ouvert et je trouve que
c'est une super belle initiative donc
moi quand on me l'a proposé je dis mais
mais mais vraiment avec grand plaisir
c'est pas si longtemps que ça que
j'habite dans les îles c'est un
département qui est grand qui est vaste
ou il se passe pas mal de choses et donc
si on peut en faire découvrir on peut
faire découvrir quelques petites actions
comme ça par ci par là je trouve que
c'est génial donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
accepté et en plus la team est super
sympa plein d'influenceurs avec
pas mal de mamans qui sont vraiment
investies on a un homme quand même dans
la team donc c'est voilà on s'entend
très très bien c'est toujours au bon
enfant et c'est très très sympa de se
retrouver et de pouvoir après mettre en
avant donc toutes ces actions sur les
réseaux sociaux bien sûr pour pouvoir
les passer aujourd'hui
et d'ailleurs il y a le Pass plus moi
j'en parle parce que le passe plus j'ai
trouvé ça génial aussi que cette action
je savais pas que ça existait alors moi
je j'ai un petit garçon qui est encore
trop petit parce qu'il est en primaire
mais dès qu'il sera au collège je
pourrais je pourrais avoir le passe plus
en plus il y a pas de niveau de tous les
parents peuvent avoir accès à ça tous
les enfants qui habitent qui sont
domiciliés ou scolarisés dans les
Yvelines qui peuvent avoir le passe plus
c'est ça leur permet d'avoir un
porte-monnaie électronique de 80 € à peu
près pour des
activités sportives ou culturelles c'est
génial je trouve enfin il faut pas
passer à côté je trouve que c'est
encourageant d'ailleurs pour les enfants
pour leur faire faire du sport pour les
parents bah ça limite un peu le budget
dans le 80 euros c'est génial de voilà
c'est en moins dans le budget donc il
faut en profiter donc c'est plein
d'actions comme ça qu'on fait découvrir
et je trouve que c'est top alors vous
l'avez dit vous êtes dans les Yvelines
depuis peu vous avez toujours été en
revanche en région parisienne qu'est-ce
que vous aimez particulièrement dans ce
département des Yvelines je trouve que
c'est très vert c'est un département qui
est très vert
donc ça ça c'est vraiment ça fait du
bien il y a beaucoup de forêts
il y a des champs à perte de vue mais il
y a beaucoup de forêts on peut faire du
vélo assez facilement j'en fais beaucoup
avec la fille
c'est hyper important on peut faire du
cheval aussi il y a beaucoup de centres
équestres
enfin pas mal d'activités je trouve dans
les Yvelines on peut respirer ça finit
on est vraiment pas très loin de Paris
on est allé à une demi-heure à peu près
de voilà de l'entrée de Paris je trouve
que c'est vraiment pas loin et on arrive
et c'est un poumon vert je trouve que
enfin ça dépend où est-ce qu'on habite
dans les Yvelines mais quand même en
règle générale c'est assez vert et on
peut vite voilà ça irait la tête et
trouver une forêt se balader donc c'est
ouais non c'est vraiment une personne
vous allez y rester encore
ici ouais merci beaucoup Sandrine
narciset ce sera le mot de la fin on le
rappelle l'un à la sortie de votre livre
très prochainement pour la rentrée un
livre de sport on vous retrouve famille
en famille on vous retrouve également
sur C8 et dans le département des
Yvelines dans ce petit merci
[Musique]